[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream number 68q
and a um we are going to
attempt to address your questions with
answers as
always we have an announcement up top
though
the winner of the
clubhouse invite is jack passmore
congratulations jack i should point out
like sex drugs and rock and roll
clubhouse is not to be used
recreationally and please don't get
addicted
all right
all right even rock and roll even rock
and roll right well here
here's my my thought on that is that um
music is a very powerful manipulator of
the mind and so you should just be
careful who you let in there
and uh you know who you allowed to in
inform you musically
um i don't mean in any of these cases i
don't mean you shouldn't enjoy it of
course you should enjoy it all of them
thoroughly but you know very potent
stuff no junk sex
no drugs drugs no junk rock and roll no
junk clubhouse
there you go yeah exactly okay
all right uh we will begin as has become
uh the usual with a few questions from
last time that we didn't get to
first one what is the benefit of
investing in wings for a creature before
flight is fully evolved
is there a benefit to wings like gliding
or running up steep hills before flight
is fully evolved
great question yeah it is a great
question um
i would like to answer it with a
two-hour lecture on the evolution of
flight and feathers
and endothermy and birds but i'm not
going to i have given that lecture
in the past um yeah yeah i mean
isn't it fair to say that in
almost every case of wings if not every
case
there is a gliding precursor and
gliding can be a very highly efficient
behavior as you can see if you've ever
watched
so-called flying fish and
flying squirrels the degree of control
and of lift
well yes lift i suppose that they get
and therefore the glide distance is
stunning
so and there's a question so you know
flying squirrels and flying fish do this
rather differently flying fish have to
actually launch themselves out of their
normal substrate
up before they actually before we see
them
all right and whereas flying squirrels
are you know tend to lose a little bit
um but start high and and somewhat lower
but still in the trees unless something
has gone wrong the
um the snakes that have um big surfaces
with which they can effectively navigate
air
as all the videos i've seen and talking
to the people who do the research on
them they tend to
it tends to be a way for them to launch
themselves out of trees
and onto the ground and they're um
either escaping from or
a predator or going after prey by doing
so
um birds two
of the um two of the imagined ecologies
that were going on was so
so i said um flight feathers endothermic
is actually a fourth thing on that list
that have been like played around with a
lot by people who are thinking about
this like
flight feathers endothermy and
arboriality tree dwelling like which of
these things
must have come before the others which
of them likely did like what is the
order of evolution of these four traits
in um in early birdness or you know
proto-birdness
um and it's not it's not fully resolved
but you know one of the reasons to
imagine that our boreality came before
wings
is that you know just like with the
snakes who do this
that having some some kind of gliding
surface
with which you can you can control
yourself a little bit
would be useful for getting out of trees
fast if you're a bird
um but then there's a question about
whether or not um
it was that situation where early bird
stuff evolved or maybe it was cliff
dwellers
right like so you're launching yourself
off off a cliff and
um and being able to ride thermals and
such and then
hopefully you know getting back maybe
maybe to the side of a cliff and working
your way back up but you know it's not
totally clear exactly what the
what happens there if you don't have
powered flight and so can't reliably go
go back up yes keep moving down
yeah yeah it's hard to imagine how the
cliff thing works for exactly that
reason you know thermals would have to
be totally reliable to get you back to
to your starting point but trees
obviously can be climbed
which raises an interesting question
i've always thought the distinction
between flying and gliding
was a little bit um overdrawn
because in some sense gliding is powered
flight where
you sort of you know load wait what did
you say gliding is powered flight but
you're loading the power in when you
climb the tree
and then uh utilize well it's like all
energy is solar though i mean like
i mean you know it's true at exactly the
same level like sure if you go far back
enough but
it's indirect effects at best i agree
but i mean at least it is worth
noting that you know it's uh it is
powered in a different way
and um and that it you know it's a very
it's a
gentle slope in the adaptive landscape
from gliding to flying
if you can figure out how to add power
uh during flight then
you can prolong the glide effectively
and so it's relatively easy to see how
it would
um would evolve but yeah um you know
it's a fascinating topic and the fact
you know i think i said
several weeks ago that convergent
evolution
was a tremendous gift to evolutionary
biology because without it we would only
have one example of everything and it's
very hard to say anything with one
example well gliding
and flying are lovely because we have
multiple examples of both
and therefore it can build a kind of
model of how this works
now you used to make a joke in your bat
lectures
uh which given what you just said i feel
like you you couldn't make it anymore
you would say
that the as far as we know the closest
extent relative
of bats is a
dermopterin right which is a flying
labor flying lemur
which is called a flying lemur because
it doesn't fly and isn't the lemur
right yeah um
yeah i mean i agree with you i'm not
saying that there is no distinction
between
what we call powered flight and gliding
but it's like
a differently powered flight yes um but
there's a reason
we don't make you the language sar let's
just call that differently powered
flight from oh good
okay now right we're all more confused
okay
next question um regarding taking the
vaccine after a previous infection
would first testing negative for
antibodies change your analysis
or and or change the possibility of
reinfection
it's a good question i might be more
interested in the killer t cells
right that's the problem is that
antibodies in this case are functioning
as a proxy well both antibodies
and killer t cells are involved in the
immune response that deals
with um with a virus like like
like sars kobe 2. the absence of
antibodies does not necessarily mean
an absence of killer t cells
so it's not a perfect proxy but let's
just say you know but it's
as good a ones we've got potentially or
it's at least a good cheap one right you
can you can find it easily um because
antibodies can be tested for it directly
um so you know yes i would love to know
what these things are i would also just
you know by the hour we are discovering
or at least in a position to discover
something about whether or not you
become
vulnerable to reinfection right and so
far what we think we know
is that reinfection rates are not zero
but it is very very rare
and it could be that the immunity wanes
over time
but i would also point out that there is
a comparison to be made
between the type of immunity that will
be generated
by a vaccine of this type
and the kind of immunity that will be
generated by
actual um battling of sarsakovi to
the virus itself and the difference is
this and it has all sorts of
implications about how
likely this vaccine is to work to get us
to something like herd immunity
all of those things and maybe we should
revisit this on a live stream later on
but the basic
comparison would be this if you've had
sars cov2 if you've if you've contracted
covet 19
you've been exposed to all of the
components of the
virus and your immune system can
essentially
build a response to any protein right
any protein of a sufficient size
so you would imagine that the immunity
that you would get from
covid19 would be broader than the
vaccine which has chosen the spike
protein narrowly and all of them have
chosen it right so all of the various
manufacturers
have used the same protein which so
there's going to be two effects one
you would imagine that if the virus was
going to adapt
in response to the uh immunity
that correctly identifies the spike
protein
that somebody who had had sars kovi to
the virus itself would be potentially
immune
to the novel uh the novel variants
so maybe better immunity would come out
of having had the illness it's not worth
having it's not a good thing because of
all the damage it does to the body
but nonetheless it could be broader
immunity but also from the point of view
of the evolution of the virus itself to
the extent that we globally challenge it
with one protein that we've all cribbed
from the same
you know the same uh sequence
then that is a very intense selective
signal
for the virus to evolve in such a way
that that protein is no longer present
or visible to
uh the immune system it's potentially
going to be our achilles
the immunity achilles heel for us
population wide right now i don't
i don't blame us for doing that but at
this point it's now
long enough in and we've got some
vaccines it's time to start thinking
about what is the best
collective approach right you know you
could potentially be immunizing people
with two different vaccines that had
similar effectiveness and
a slightly different focus and
potentially that would be a way of
you know in the same way that ultimately
what we did that
allowed us to manage hiv was challenge
it with a cocktail of different drugs
and
um the argument i would make is that we
should have seen that as an
as an attack vector vector early on
because the point is
you can adapt relative to one thing
easily but if you have multiple
challenges simultaneously you adapt
to avoid this one and you move into the
um
the vulnerability to that one so
multiple vaccines could potentially be
part of a coordinated
assault anyway maybe we should table
that here and come back to it
uh as a deeper dive at some other point
yep brett david schmucktenberger said
market solving problems is a moot point
with nasa
honeywell boeing bulova general electric
grumman and many more contractors
market solved the problems that nasa
identified what are your thoughts
um i think daniel has a point
um i would say fusion is the better
example
that the market has had a very hard time
solving a problem whose
exact dimensions we know and the reason
is that
the profit is so far down the road that
anybody who's looking
to get rich is unlikely to invest and at
some point we will get close enough
that you know the market will solve it
and it may even seem like hey the market
was the right answer all along but the
point is actually we should have been
here 25 years ago
right we should have we'd be far better
off and
the fact that it didn't is evidence of
what daniel was saying
that you need to be able to cur but
here's the point what i'm saying
is the right way to use the market is to
basically point the market at things
problems you want solved you point the
market at them
and you say all right now do the market
magic thing right
you can point the market at the problem
of fusion you can add a subsidy the
government can say this is a problem
that needs solving it's solvable
and here is what we are going to do to
incentivize its solution in the same way
that a private entity might offer a
prize for
the solution so it is not a question of
either or
i think the right answer is markets are
a tool
they are not magic right they have
properties that are
almost like magic right just the same
way selection does
but the real question is can you figure
out how to
wield them effectively without allowing
them to do a lot of collateral damage
and
that's all readily doable so anyway i
would say in this case
um daniel's point is right but it
doesn't exist in isolation both
points exist together
very good final question from episode 67
can multiculturalism exist without
cultural appropriation
i think this is a this is a great
framing and no
unless i mean unless you're seeking
parallel societies which is not really
multiculturalism
it's um a kind of extreme form of live
and let live which probably doesn't work
anyway um but of course there's
borrowing and
you know this have any cultural
values been appropriated inappropriately
uh yes of course and so you know is the
concept of cultural appropriation a
legitimate one
yes at base but um i
i feel about it i guess at this point a
bit like i feel about
uh the trans debate where like there's a
real thing
there's a real thing known as trans and
there are real people who really suffer
and there are real cultures who have had
their values or norms basically you know
minimized or you know stripped from them
as a result of some other culture coming
in
and stealing or betraying or whatever it
is
but um just as most of the people who
are currently in the debate
over in trans rights activist space
right now i don't think are good faith
um and are for the most part not doing
anything good for the very tiny tiny
number of people who are actually truly
trans
uh i don't think um that the vast number
of
accusations of cultural appropriation at
this point have anything to do
with actual harm to uh culture
um it's it's power it's about power
again
uh and a misunderstanding of what
history is and what
and what people do i mean this this is
exactly how cultures evolve they evolve
sometimes by creating new things and
often by borrowing and adding
and you can see in fact that um a lot of
things
i think a lot of people who deploy you
know the idea cultural appropriation is
bad you're taking stuff you're not
paying for it right okay
i can sort of see the perspective on the
other hand this is what culture is this
is why we're not hardwired
um and so you know at some level you
should expect this
but you know the point is if you start
to put these things together
you realize what this is is a set of
rules that
cannot be abided by right so i saw today
coca-cola a
internal anti-racism
briefing escaped you know about
whiteness right
be less white or something like that
well okay
be less white and don't culturally
appropriate
it is hard to disappear yourselves right
like don't don't exist
well the basic point is look you're
going to be in violation of one of these
things or the other so basically watch
your step because we can convict you on
a moment's notice we're watching and
we're in charge now
right used to it and likewise i would
say uh
you know i'm going to hate myself for
speaking like a child now
but um for the moment right the
the discussion around the n-word has
gotten completely preposterous and i'm
now
you know one of the wonderful things
about clubhouse is you can actually
listen in on discussions and you can
learn how people think about this but
at some level the word
is now super ubiquitous in
uh features in quadrants of black
culture
right i find no problem with that but to
do that to infuse a you know hip-hop
culture or whatever
with this word so it's everywhere and
then
to hold a super high bar where somebody
who's simply singing along with a song
trips over it and is then convicted as
if they you know
used it as an epithet against someone is
preposterous
you know it's again a trap and so anyway
what we need is a an adult discussion
in which the proper level of nuance is
there
so that we can distinguish for example
between um
wielding an epithet and mentioning the
epithet or
you know using the epithet as you are
inhabiting a character a racist
character is it wrong to inhabit a
racist character and you know use the
syllables
right no of course not right we need
racist characters in order to understand
the problem with racism right
so um so in any case you can't deploy
all of these things in isolation and
then combine them into some
web that can't be uh can't be navigated
yeah
okay the question from the discord this
week
uh is do you believe there is such a
thing as women's intuition
and if you do how and why did it develop
ah i have no idea whether you'd like to
start
i'll go for it okay what i would say is
a intuition is a huge deal it just goes
back to the discussion
that we were having about how you
formulate hypotheses
i would say intuition is a skill it's a
skill that
can be well tutored if you are
thoroughly well versed in something your
intuitions about things and
things in that neighborhood are likely
to be very high quality if you do not
have a lot of grounding in a subject
your intuitions are liable to be
garbagey
and so intuition is a thing and
intuition can be anything from
scientific intuition to intuition about
the weather that might come from having
lived in a particular location and
having noticed
you know that the afternoons like this
tend to proceed evenings like that or
whatever
so there will very definitely 100
be intuitions that women will have about
all sorts of things that may
be colored by the fact of their being
female
i would say given what we know to be
a universal but population level
difference
in the interests even of babies wherein
male babies are more likely to show
interest in things and female babies are
more likely to show interest in faces
um people faces animal faces and from
that
it has been extrapolated i think
correctly
that the interests that um girls and
boys and then women and men show later
on
um which then do see you may well
turn into differences in ability but not
necessarily
um around you know women being more
likely to
pursue uh careers where they're engaging
with people you know forward-facing as
opposed to
back of the stuff you know doing the the
boxing and the
and the fiddling with the gadget stuff
um you know caring careers versus
engineering careers you know these sorts
of things
um you know it have you know have there
been barriers to entry
for thing-based careers for women in the
past of course there have been
um and have there indeed been barriers
to entry for caring-based careers for
men in the past
sure also um but the differences
in income between the two types of
careers which is also
probably in part a result of some sort
of systemic sexism in the past
has meant that there's but there have
been fewer men who've been trying to get
into the caring careers and then there
have been women who
would have been interested in getting
into the you know science and
engineering and you know stem type
careers
all of that said i would say that
um in part because of the kinds of
things
that men are more interested in and
because they are more conducive
to quantification and description with
careful analytical language
that when that the type of intuition
that males on average will have
might actually be more easy to describe
so that you can be like i had this idea
and i think i can actually now go back
and and track it
and um i think perhaps for two reasons
because
the kinds of things that women as a
population on average are more
interested in are about social dynamics
um which are are harder
to chase down to you know to reduce
you know accurately to a a very
fundamental level they are inherently
part of a complex system they are
inherently more emergent they are
inherently part of a complex system
and maybe also because it has typically
been women's domain and women's domain
has had less attention paid to it i'm
less sure of that
but at least for the first reason and
maybe for the second i think
the kinds of things that women as a
population are likely to
have intuition about are are going to be
less conducive
to an explanation um of of the sort
that everyone can understand just by
using language
um so you know every everyone will have
intuition we will tend to have intuition
about different things
one of the predictors about what kind of
intuition we are likely
to have is going to be sex-based it's
one of one of many things they're going
to predict that
and are you know women-type intuition
things
um less likely to be easily explicable
uh through language and analysis i think
so
yeah and so are they likely to is that
likely to live in the domain of like
magic and woo even though it may be
just as accurate we just don't know all
of the things that went into it
yeah i think so cool yeah i think i
think there's a lot here
and i agree that um the noisier
the more complex uh system the noisier
the uh patterns tend to be and therefore
the earlier that intuition tends
uh to work or intuition tends to work
early
maybe later you know enough about the
system to you know describe it in
in uh more rigorous terms but you know
there's a trade-off
the point is and this goes right back
actually
to this question we were dealing with
earlier about the formulation of
hypotheses
which involves trafficking in bad ideas
in order to spot the one that isn't
really bad
yeah that involves license
right license to not falsify everything
based on something that you know but
you know to give things enough room to
unfold that you can actually spot you
know that wrong hypothesis
might not be wrong um which you know i
guess my claim is
that's an intuitive process and there
are people who are really good at it and
there are people who are not really good
at it and it's very hard to tell you you
know
how do you formulate a good novel
hypothesis
um well you formulate an intuition right
okay
well it's black boxed right there yeah
yep absolutely
all right uh first question from today's
live stream
brett it's 2017 evergreen library
fourth floor you walked up to the podium
and looked like you were prepared to
speak but you turned around and went
back to your seat
what were you going to say and why did
you choose not to speak
um well you know what i was going to say
because i've said it all
somewhere and yeah but what were you
going to say then
well i was going to make the point that
i couldn't possibly be the racist that
they thought i was
um and that there was you know no
shortage of information
i was going to cop to the fact that i'd
undoubtedly have bigotry
that basically you know i don't know
what it is like to be
a woman to be black to be gay to be
trans i don't know any of these things
firsthand i'm interested
it's not voluntary ignorance but i will
always have a degree of ignorance about
those things
but i am very interested and committed
to the idea
of a colorblind society and there's a
very good reason for it it's the only
one that's going to work to solve the
problem
that's approximately what i was going to
say now what happened i remember
very distinctly so what happened was
i was there this made certain people
irate
right if we put him in danger why is he
here now i never said they had put me in
danger at that point i felt endangered
in that
room right and in fact i was told i
wasn't going to be allowed to leave so i
had every reason to feel endangered in
that room
and there was no way for the police or
anyone else to get in there was a
hallway full of anarchists blocking the
entrance but um
nonetheless i felt i should be there to
defend myself
um you know so i went
people saw that i was there and because
i was sitting there quietly
their point was well you know why
doesn't he get up to the podium
you know because we've got a few things
to ask him and my sense was
okay i'm going to the podium and i got
up
and as soon as they saw that i was eager
to get to the podium and i was willing
to confront them and i
you know wasn't going to be back down
with fear their points don't let him
speak he loves speaking
right and in fact it's almost exactly
what they said it was something like uh
you know it's exactly what he wants or
something like that it's the same thing
if you're quiet you're racist if you're
speaking you're racist like you know
it's it's an unwinnable situation and
the the marvelous thing about what
happened at evergreen in those
days and weeks was that it was on such
ludicrous public display
that the the ways in which they created
worlds that were internally inconsistent
to suit the
the mood of the moment and were willing
to
just switch it seconds later yeah was
more obvious than maybe it has been in
any in any of the other
meltdowns that have happened now in so
many demands yeah i mean
it was just you know purer and more over
the top
and um so it made every point really
really well if you were tracking it and
you know
um thank god for benjamin boyce
who uh you know wrestled so much of the
evidence
uh into public view and you know sorted
through it in such a careful way that
it's actually
encyclopedically available right yeah
anything you want to know about what
happened or almost anything
you can find out because he's cataloged
it all in every direction and he's
interviewed everybody he could
um he just showed up thank god for
benjamin boyce great to see you thank
you benjamin boyce and thank god for
mike nena who uh took the vast library
of benjamin
voice materials and other stuff and
wrestled it into a very tight three-part
documentary for people to
if you want a mere hour and a half right
but you know if you want the you know
the quick and dirty but
highly accurate version that's the way
to go in any case
you know it's just lovely that the thing
got completely categorized and sorted
you know it was like a it was like an
faa investigation of a crash right like
all you know it all got assembled in a
hangar and now we can describe
like every instant you could do a
timeline yeah as i remember
you know every time early on that uh
that benjamin
would go to get you know to do public
records requests
they're like you know to use your
analogy of the faa crash
evergreen was like well you can't have
our black box like no no no no no no
we're gonna put a barrier against
barrier barrier barrier here
because we really don't want to show
those things to you oh fine we have to
oh dear
now we look even stupider than we did
before right now i think they've gotten
much better at actually just not
responding to these requests
and they've also they've done terrible
things to benjamin they've
gone after his channel right they've
never i didn't know that they're
interfering in his ability to earn a
livelihood on
youtube and you know what are you gonna
do you're up against an institution
and although it is you know starving for
money and
only still functioning because the state
subsidizes it at an extreme level now
that it's down to such a small fraction
of its initial population
but nonetheless they have money to spend
on pr because of course
you know you would want pr to get more
students so they can
use that argument but then they can use
their pr team to figure out how to uh
you know
demonize benjamin or obscure what he's
doing or
uh it's a nightmare you are occasionally
still hassleless
yeah well there you go all right
next question let's get to the important
stuff do you wash your dog with shampoo
or without
and how often my black labrador sends
her regards
have we ever washed our dog um yeah
she is she is she will be eight
in march i believe we use none of the
things you mentioned
i guess i'm the only one who does it
sounds like you never do i use
bleach and in fact she is a black did
she ingest it
no uh no she's a black lab our lab is
not a black lab
oh oh my gosh
okay her nose did mold early on
her nose was black she did have a much
darker nose yeah
um no seriously how do we get away like
i clean her i i scrub her down every
time i bring her in when it's gross out
who washes their labrador
um i watch the labrador
when she rolls in something she
shouldn't matty right we spread we spray
with isopropyl
we do and and and rub her down yeah
but i mean that's the you know she goes
out in the rain and she gets wet and we
shake her off outside and tile her down
and i guess not without shampoo we wash
her with brain
rain and isopropyl alcohol occasionally
when she grows and
grows in something anoxic that she finds
delightful and we don't yes
there you go yeah okay
oh so this one um terrible new york
times interpretation of cdc data
with the links supplied i suggest
reading and sharing uh why do so many
not ask hard questions study the data or
report on the facts willful ignorance
ignorance or puppet mastery um that's
from someone named crystal
um i clicked on the link and the link is
broken i don't know
that may just feed into exactly what
you're saying but um we're gonna need
another version of that link in order to
see what you're talking about
regarding cc
um cc i don't what's cc
green is clearwater no
why not preference those solutions that
would still help society even if it's
proven false
for instance nuclear rather than
solutions that only help if it's true
for instance carbon tax
seems like a way to win over the
skeptics here's our dog smelling of
isopropyl right now
oh she brought us a donut so do you
understand this question i don't i don't
yet um this is someone this is mauricio
dark who asks a lot of excellent
questions um
regarding cc why not preference those
solutions that would still help
society even if it's proven false for
instance nuclear rather than solutions
climate change thank you um
rather than solutions that only help if
it's true for instance carbon tax seems
like
oh see okay yeah yes right actually it's
reminiscent of
that uh wonderful cartoon from so many
years ago
um you know i i forget exactly it's a
guy at a podium
and it's a list of all of the things
that are proposed and somebody says
um the equivalent of uh
what if climate change is a hoax and we
make civilization
way better for no reason yeah
yeah absolutely and that's the thing is
of course you should do those things
which work either way
and the problem the elephant in the room
is the forces that are currently winning
that have a concentrated private
interest in preventing us from
replacing whatever industries they're in
with better industries you know who
killed the electric car that kind of
logic right now
i have thought i think i've had this
thought since high school
certainly since college but the answer
is
if you had to buy out these industries
in order to save the world
let's just buy them out right i mean
it's worth the price we're going to pay
is incalculable so whenever the price
might be
so but who all are you talking about
though so like oil and gas anything
anything petroleum related but then
you're talking about
airplanes and cars and no like you know
natural gas in the home too like
my point really is we have a corruption
problem and we have
a long-standing corruption problem and
it comes in the form of those who have
made a profit doing x have
every interest in your prov in
preventing you from realizing that x is
not a long-term
sustainable technology yep so as a
result we do lots of unsustainable stuff
and then we engage magical thinking
about cornucopian
solutions technology will always save us
all of these things which will
ultimately be wrong and will ultimately
kill us
my point is simply they are doing a cost
benefit calculation
right the cost of the corruption that
they collectively visit upon our system
will be total right therefore
i mean look we can absorb huge costs
right
covet 19 is uh is it a 17 trillion
dollar
virus i haven't heard the number but
anyway i've heard that but
i don't know that that's a robust number
i also you know that would be a
temporary number because the costs
continue to grow
um so the point is what is the price
point of hey can we
in directly engage in confronting the
climate question and that means figuring
out
which part of our understanding of
climate change is robust which part of
it is the result of academic politics
and self-fulfilling
um you know models and things like that
and you know how do we sort out
what the actual hazard to us is what the
level of urgency is
what the appropriate solutions are as
our questioner asks what are the things
that we can invest in that work either
way
yes how do we how do we get private
interests out from between
us and public policy period it's the
most
obvious thing that we need to do in
order for civilization to work
and you know the problem is it's the
elephant in the room and it's been the
elephant in the room for so long
that we've stopped even mentioning it
even those of us who talk about it
it's just stepping over the elephant
right yeah yeah we're just like
clambering over the elephant
hey fred right so uh
yeah yeah let's let's deal with fred the
elephant finally
let's do it brett said that when civil
war was about to happen the two sides
started portraying one another as
inhuman in order to make it easier to
think of themselves
each other as enemies what are some
examples of this
any resources to learn more um i think
my claim was about war in
general i don't think civil war is
special in this regard i think that's
right um
i don't remember exactly what this is
referencing yeah and in fact that
thought
i'm trying to remember what my source
was that thought dawned on me
about this sort of this biological
module that causes us to dehumanize
those we are about to
um to fight in order to make to
facilitate our willingness to kill them
and not
be you know overwhelmed by guilt i feel
like sapolsky may have written about
this in the past
uh yeah it's probably in behave yeah
although
remembering but um but any case yeah
certainly start with
sapolsky that that's a you're sure to
get
um he's wonderful so you're not gonna
you're not going to not learn things
even if it's not that you'll learn a ton
that's highly relevant to the question
even if it's not
uh directly addressed in behave yeah and
i don't actually i have not spent as
much time with behave as i have with
this earlier stuff
i mean i was i was i was i was using him
as
my research when i was working on um sex
differences and behavior and primates as
an undergraduate
so you know he's and you know
specifically
um things things like aggression and
conciliatory behavior and such
yep um i am remembering though somewhere
in
teaching at evergreen i encountered
probably as a result of a teaching
partner who
favored it a documentary in which
interviews were done with
soldiers and they were compared with
um these racist
cartoons that were you know
mainstreamed about you know the enemy
that was going to be genocided or fought
um and it was just very clear what was
going on
right and um anyway
sorry that's not a better source but um
i think it's a
it's a robust pattern and if you look
undoubtedly you'll
you'll find it sapolsky is a good place
to start
um hey zach my computer doesn't seem to
be plugged in and i'm losing power
quickly
um i don't know if you can just do
something on your end
i know i'm i've just i've only got the
working end of the plug
next question yes redheads why do men
love them so much
why are they correlated with having
freckles and why don't gingers have
souls
evolutionarily speaking
so that's a deeply loaded question
thank you um yeah yeah i'm i'm
i i mean yeah the the freckles thing is
gonna be about it correlating with very
very pale skin yeah that it's it's a
it's a sort of one end of the melanin
spectrum
yep um yeah so well we can do the
freckle thing actually probably the best
here i would say that the world's
leading expert on
uh the redhead phenomenon is tim
mentioned
the comedian i don't know who that is um
only a gender can call it gender gender
yeah yeah anyway that song has a lot
but anyway let's talk about the freckle
part so uh
years ago when i was um getting involved
in the telomere question and and all of
those things
it occurred to me that there was a
missing phenomenon
in the literature which i
labeled and the label never took off but
i i called it prototumors
and the idea was that telomeres which
count down the number of cellular
divisions and arrest
a cell at a certain number so that it
will not even though it's healthy and
could divide again it just doesn't
um that the
that counting down was a matter of
preventing tumors that a cell that
lost track of how much reproduction it
was supposed to do would run into this
limit
and so you would stop getting a tumor
because
cells that became dysregulated would
grow to a certain size or
to a certain patch size and then stop
what were those patches called
nobody knew so i said it's called a
prototumor
they'll be all through your body and on
your skin it's very likely that that's
the
nature of moles and freckles now we now
know that this is true for moles
right but not true moles
i'm tempted to tell you that's spelled
differently but i have a feeling it
isn't
no not true moles darling um right so
in any case a mole it turns out is a
cell that has become dysregulated
has created a bunch of copies of itself
that are all equally disregulated
because the dysregulation is genetic so
it passes on
the defect and then typically becomes
colorful now the reason
is still hypo hypothetical my hypothesis
for why
is that if a cell has become
dysregulated and has duplicated itself
many times then if it gets a second
mutation that turns on telomerase it
will become a tumor and so how do you
prevent a second mutation on a skin cell
you put melanin in it so that uv
radiation is less likely to trigger a
second mutation
right so my claim is that that also
probably applies to freckles now as far
as i know this has never been
established for freckles i'm not sure
anybody has looked into it when
i was doing this work back in 1998 or
nine
basically the literature all said the
same thing about freckles which was that
they weren't
important um didn't describe what they
were phenomenologically i know because i
got a sunburn in honduras in 1991.
yes 1991 snorkeling the water was cool i
wasn't paying attention to the fact that
the sun was blazing
got a wicked bad sunburn on my back and
after it healed
i had this basically giant patch of
freckles that were so
many that they had all joined together
into large orange splotches so my
thought was lots of mutations
that would fit the same pattern okay so
the basic point is
for whatever reason redheads are
correlated
with a very pale skin very vulnerable
to uv radiation why do men like them
probably it's just a novelty
effect and i don't think
it's all men in fact i think there are
cultures
where it's not particularly privileged
but
anyway i think why are they soulless
um i cannot confirm that they are
soulless i have actually known
some people with red hair and i find
them
very human so i cannot confirm that part
of the model okay
okay next question i lived through the
2007 midwest ice storm four inches of
ice two weeks without power my city
underwent adaptation and to this day all
power lines are cleared of overhanging
branches
do you think portland should do the same
i think all of us should realize that we
are
paying a huge psychic price for these
things and we pay a price in the
vulnerability of our systems and so
i will say two things about this one our
grid
is a nightmare and for no particularly
good reason yes it would cost an awful
lot to put
lines underground but we should
basically turn that into a
decade or 15-year project and we should
work our way there just to make the
system
more robust and to stop paying the
psychic price of seeing this
garbagey stuff you know in every
landscape
um that was one thing what was the other
thing i wanted to say
um i don't know
but i will say that um you know some
parts of portland
weren't particularly badly hit and those
are the parts without much nature left
and um you know you can and indeed i saw
on next door someone said you know see
yeah we should cut down
all the trees so that we don't have this
problem like how about
you live somewhere else you know where
there aren't trees and
you know we i have we've been places
where the utilities have been put
underground and there are of course
risks to that especially in earthquake
country as we are all along the west
coast
um but the much more frequent risks
are the ones that we are experiencing
now with regard to you know a you know
the farther and south you go the more
likely there's fire risk from blowing in
the wind under very dry circumstances
and here we've got ice risk
um and at least in
in the southwest hills um which isn't
exactly where we are but we're in
in that general area of portland uh
there
are there remain a ton of trees and if
you were actually try
going to try to clear all branches
from anywhere near where they could fall
on a power line
you would effectively strip the
landscape of trees and then you'd have
landslide issues then you know then
you'd have a whole other set of issues
and you would have effectively denuded
and made ugly um
exactly the you know the part of
portland that is most like
uh what the landscape was you know
probably 200 years ago
whereas if you put the lines underground
you make
uh the place better you make it more
robust
far safer um
the other thing i wanted to mention was
that the basically what you're finding
is a risk to things like the grid that
come
from very rare events so ice storms are
rare enough that we're not well
buttressed and basically the idea is
stuff will fall
you know there's a certain amount of
clearing of branches every year to
prevent this a certain amount of taking
down of trees
it's not enough to deal with the ice
storm problem
so stuff goes down we put it back
up you know and the cycle repeats but
the point is we ought to be
incentivized to make a much more robust
situation because for one thing if
that situation interfaced with some
second disaster just temporarily
speaking it's very very dangerous
right because everything depends on your
ability to you know to
call emergency services uh to be able to
drive your vehicle out to get provisions
whatever it is so
there's a lot to be done but there's an
even much more
dangerous vulnerability in our grid that
at the point we find out
uh how vulnerable we are it may well be
too late and this has to do
with our vulnerability to
carrington-like events
which are basically solar in nature the
sun can spit out
uh radiation that can cause our
transformers to blow
these are the major transformers in the
system and there is no mechanism to get
them back online or replace them in
good time so anyway it's a topic for
another day but we have many
vulnerabilities like this and frankly
because this is one of the defects of
markets
is it causes this razor sharp focus on
efficiency
on some short time scale and the point
is you're not paying attention to the
vulnerability you've just created on a
longer time scale and
it wouldn't be hard to get smart about
this but it does involve us not
you know wagging our fingers at those in
governance who want to invest
in uh remote
possibilities that over a long period of
time become probabilities
good what secret skill does clubhouse
have that won't turn it into a public
sewer sewer of mismanaged community
standards
excited running to the next social media
without solving the problems of the
first
seems problematic well i don't
know whether it has the ability
unfortunately the market is very likely
to cause
clubhouse to be sold to somebody it
could vary i heard a discussion
yesterday could very well be sold to
facebook in which case it would acquire
exactly the myopia that facebook clearly
has
there are different people involved
in clubhouse and frankly those different
people have been participating
in rooms with us so to the extent that
there is a very committed
small group of very clear-headed people
saying we have
an opportunity to do things here that
opportunity is jeopardized by the fact
that zero is a special number and they
will
attempt to do to clubhouse what has
happened everywhere else for the purpose
of narrative control
right and we can't let that happen
there's something much more important
than money riding on this
maybe those people will recognize you
know what
let's not go down the same road and
there's signs that they won't
right so for example uh so far there are
no ads there
and the discussion suggests that the
founders don't want ads to become part
of the model
so if that's how is it funded at the
moment it's
you know venture capital right so that's
not sustainable
right but they can do things and they
are considering doing things in which
you will be able to use
clubhouse to do things like podcast
and people will be able to pay you you
know basically will incorporate a
patreon-like
phenomenon so you know that's a business
model
uh that might well be immune to some of
these things so
hopefully the founders and funders of
clubhouse will realize that
because it is different that it must be
preserved and that requires them to
avoid the business model driven traps
that have swallowed all of the other
um social media platforms well as you
know i have an uh
particular aversion to early adoption
especially of tech stuff
um i i lean towards the luddite in this
regard especially in social media space
um so i'm
i hear your answer but i don't accept
that it's a complete answer
oh it's not a complete answer i think
the danger is real and frankly i think
that the
um the difference between having
clubhouse where we can say the things
that we can't necessarily say on twitter
is so substantial with respect to the
narrative control that i would expect
um every avenue to be explored to shut
down that opportunity
you know hence the concern over this
question of unfettered conversation and
misinformation and how do we stamp that
out so
we'll see yep i've heard that diseases
are most contagious right before
symptoms show
is that a biological observation that we
shed most material then
or an epidemiological observation that
we most likely transfer disease when
unaware of it
that's a that's a really terrific
awesome question and i actually don't
know
the basis um i i guess
now that it is parsed that way um i
the epidemiological explanation um
is certainly true regardless of whether
or not
what you're calling the biological one
is as well i would say
that that you're you're not going to be
mitigating your behavior before you know
you're sick um
right you're gonna be behaving as normal
yeah so i think there are lots of levels
at which this
and i think they all point in the same
direction including the modern one
which is um germ theory of disease
allows us now to understand that we are
contagious
right and because we are contagious and
have some idea that we are transmitting
microbes and
are tend to be surrounded by people that
we give a damn about either because
we're related to them
or because we work with them or because
they're our friends
we have an incentive not to spread
things also
there's the humiliation of having given
somebody a cold or whatever so
that plays in and that's novel but the
the underlying model is that
symptoms are the result of damage
typically not every symptom symptoms
generally are the result of damage done
by these
microbes as they do their own bidding so
for example little lesions in the lung
where you basically have a wound that
you can't
see that is spilling virus out of cells
that are dead or dying
and then as you cough they get expelled
into the air for example
so you would expect that at the point
that you're symptomatic in other words
at the point that you have a wound big
enough to detect
in your lungs um that that would be
coincident with
these particles being uh you know
readily coughed out and things like that
um
yeah i guess i'm um i'm chagrined
by what i see uh as
a failure even after a year of this
of people to actually model what the
physics of transmission is
and you know you say well we you know we
have theory of germ theory of disease
now and so people
know and like you know i've i've gone on
about this before
way more than i want to so i don't i'm
not going to spend a lot of time
again talking about you know getting the
stink eye from people
who are wearing masks outside when i'm a
long ways away from them not wearing a
mask
but um i also had the experience
this week of you know people yes mass
but having a very loud conversation with
one another
coming like towards me and me sort of
not wearing a mask and like
veering away and like you're yelling
like i don't actu like yes your mask is
going to block some of that but you're
yelling you're spreading particles
much more so than if you were talking
and much more so if you were quiet
yeah so what i i actually do not know
like what yelling through a mask does
for the likelihood of transmitting
something as opposed to walking quietly
without vocalizing at all without a mask
but i don't my guess is that they're
they're not wildly different and if they
are different at all i'm
actually not sure which way to predict
that yeah and like i
i specifically don't want to be around
people who are yelling right now
strangers who are yelling and people
imagine that their mask is just a magic
spell yeah
if i'm masked i'm good and therefore i
can either be infected or infect you
like no jerk like you're just wrong
yep uh what were the two categories
epidemiological and biological
and violence so are you shedding most
material then which this goes actually a
little bit
different from what you were saying you
know you shedding the most material
before symptoms show or is it
epidemiological that you're that you're
more likely to transfer
when you are not mitigating your
behavior because you don't know you're
sick all right so i want to divide the
biological one
into one more category and this goes
back to something we've mentioned
dick alexander's distinction between
coughing on your
pat student's behalf versus coughing on
your own behalf to clear
dead stuff after you've beaten a
sickness
anyway what i want to point to
is that the pathogens especially a
pathogen that knows your species well
that has a long history with you your
pathogen
will have evolved to
mitigate its effect on you such that you
are effective
at passing it along so to the extent
that you coughing will tend to be
avoided by other people
and you coughing will tend not to want
to go out because you just want to
minimize your behavior and sit there and
not do things that disturb your lungs
you're not a very effective vector and
so
you could imagine that a well
a a an experienced pathogen one that has
an evolutionary history with you
would evolve to create a period in which
it hadn't it basically had spent in
order
to stave off the creation of symptoms
while
maximizing its release of particles
because that would be the sweet spot for
transmission so you would expect
evolution of the pathogens themselves to
create exactly that pattern
and the problem is that that pattern has
several other causes that would also
lead to it
and it's very hard to disentangle them
and so you know for this a biology class
we would now
figure out how to separate those
hypotheses and figure out
you know what fraction of the phenomenon
owed to each of the causes
yes okay uh we're gonna do two more here
and then move to the next
hour uh interested in your thoughts
oh actually three more here interested
in your thoughts on this idea
intersectional supremacy
belief that people with most
intersectional categories have lived
experienced superior to others lived
experience
uh i think that doesn't actually warrant
much talking i think you've nailed it i
think that's right that's the
that's the conjecture yep what do you
think of the cynopharm
vaccine um so i don't know it by that
name anyway but
the question goes on since it's a
deactivated virus would rather take it
would you rather take it than an
adenovirus vaccine does the fact that
wuhan was involved in its development
make you more or less confident in it
so again i don't know this vaccine
except for what's written into this
question but
a deactivated virus which uh
so deactivated virus rather than
adenovirus isn't actually
the right comparison well it is because
it sounds like
the deactivated virus is the virus in
question
right but adenovirus so for instance
johnson johnson and astrazeneca
have the adenovirus as the delivery
mechanism but their dna vaccines
and so deactivated virus would compare
to mrna or dna
not to the delivery mechanism um
right now so again i we probably ought
to
table this until we know more but what i
would say is first of all i want to know
what
this means by deactivated because
deactivated can mean
killed right you can take pieces of a
virus
and deliver them to the system and the
system can learn to recognize the
proteins basically you've got
garbage collection uh cells macrophages
which will pick up the uh the fragments
and then display them and the immune
system will learn them
right that's pretty safe right a
inactivated virus which it sounds like
this is is
a potentially pathogenic virus that has
been you know as you pointed out
loss of function research has resulted
in a virus that lacks capabilities like
jumping from an
a vaccinated person to an unvaccinated
person
um but anyway i'd love to know more
about this one before we
go further down that road and again does
the fact that wuhan was involved in this
development make you more or less
confident in it
um it might make me more confident
depending yeah i want to know what it
means that wuhan was involved because
yeah yeah so i'm actually going to save
this other this next question i really
want to get to but we'll get to it next
week about the endocrinological
implications of
so-called top surgery
let's begin with some questions from
this hour
in
i feel like this word's missing this one
in before the entire lexicon of fiction
gets erased for failure to pass the fact
checking
they're only trying to protect us from
things that aren't true i think this is
just a comment on
i'm not sure what the beginning there is
but um
yeah fiction fiction has no place in
this brave new world
ah i think i think is the message here
um are there potential dangers of
getting a vaccine if you've already been
infected with sars
cov2 yeah we've we've talked about this
potentially it definitely the potential
exists which doesn't mean it's a real
danger but the very but
one thing that i pointed out last time
was that by introducing spike protein
by one mechanism or another into a
person who's been sick
it is plausible to me at least
that the receptor sites that would
trigger the immune cells to go after the
virus will be occupied
by spike protein that has been the
result of vaccine and could make you
more vulnerable so
i'm not saying that that is true but i'm
saying i want somebody to tell me that's
not true and why that the question has
been studied and here's the answer
rather than let's assume it's not true
because we don't have any evidence
because we never looked
right uh
bad science versus religion early on i
got the suspicion that some academics
are using bad science to inordinately
demonize religion pun intended
how would you sift through
anti-religious bad science
that's a big question um i mean this is
more or less simple
i would say anybody who
leaps to the conclusion that religion is
a malfunction
rather than an adaptation potentially
out of place
is telling you at least they haven't
thought very deeply about the puzzle you
know for
richard dawkins to look at you know
uh you know an eye or a gill
and to say well of course that's
adaptive and who would say otherwise and
not to look at religion and have the
same response
is inconsistent and so what i want to
know is that you've at least
spotted that an adaptive explanation is
likely for this phenomenon
before you say something like you know
these beliefs cannot adapt
to the modern world because they are
predicated on
a narrative that is non-literal where
that at least is a credible argument
that does not
pretend that they were always
maladaptations
right so i would just say did you spot
that it was an adaptation before you got
to your argument
or did you skip that part and just
decide because you don't like it that
it's bad and always was
next question you hinted at an
evolutionary explanation for edible
complex
do sons have an interest in mom not
having any more male offspring because
they will be competitors for females and
thus drive away dad by taking his place
beside
besides mom no i don't think so
i think you know kids have an interest
in their parents staying together that
interest is maybe most concentrated in
the fact that it creates full siblings
rather than half siblings and full
siblings have a lot
a stronger genetic basis for cooperation
i will say the uh the edible
complex um is i believe
freud's just misunderstanding of the way
selection would work right
and so um the point is
i believe he identified something real
but misunderstood what it was
because you know i mean basically look
the idea that selection is going to
create a broken
instinct in a creature and then force an
override to it that just doesn't add up
so the point is the impulse isn't what
he thinks it is right
there is some connection i would just
say
it is a model for something
and not the thing itself
um we'll come back to it later i'm very
much looking forward to
uh you know there are aspects of freud
that i really like but
i'm really looking forward to blowing
that one up
is it ethical for a teenager who had a
confirmed case of covet 19
to receive the vaccine they're still in
high school but have a job in a dining
room of a retirement home
before those over 75 who live on their
own
there's a lot built into this question
you know ethical
for this person before this person
doesn't make sense
for a person who's had a confirmed case
to get a vaccine
before anyone else who hasn't had it and
does it make sense
to be prioritizing teenagers getting the
vaccine
um ethical
no i don't think so i think that we
should be prioritizing the people who
are at the greatest risk
for um having very bad outcomes bad
outcomes and transmission bad outcomes
and transmission which is to say the
elderly and people with
other comorbidities which presumably a
high schooler who's
working a job doesn't have the
comorbidities either
but you know maybe more important i
would say that this person
has two of the three
states that for me and i've already said
on this live stream before
um i would say i don't think that people
in any of these three demographics
should be um
prioritized for getting vaccines and
maybe not be getting vaccines
at all and that's actually where i fall
which is to say people who've already
had confirmed cases
uh children including teenagers and then
pregnant people and
um you know presumably this person
pregnant but two out of three and i
would say there's
i i don't know why they would be in a
rush to get the vaccine
i really don't right now uh i will just
add
again something we can return to the
i have the sense that we are rushing to
a situation in which
we are going to vaccinate lots of people
who shouldn't be vaccinated
in order to have a rule that says oh you
can't do this unless you were vaccinated
right
and the problem is for people who have
had covet and shouldn't probably have
the vaccine
how do you do that how do you establish
that you have covid have had covet and
therefore don't need the vaccine and
shouldn't be given
it so then can get on an airplane or
whatever else whatever else they're
going to attempt to regulate
and this is um this is a really bad
situation because there
are very good reasons that we should be
parsing very finely who gets it
and when and if we're going to force
everybody to take it just so that we can
you know
have a you know the equivalent of a
passport that lets you do
various activities then we're going to
be engaging in a medical malpractice
for the purpose of making rules simple
yep
i've been just getting an idea autonomy
recapitulates phylomomy
how do we examine immature meme
complexes the reference frames imperfect
but let these suffice
you got it you're reading it i can't see
it um
so you know it's it's a play on uh
and you and i disagree over this but
it's a play on an
inaccurate um saying from early
developmental biology which is ontogeny
recapitulates phylogeny which means that
in development you go through looking
like
all of your ancestors did at some point
um
and in in fact you said that's uh
i'd have to look up my lectures on on on
this on um
on on this the three-fold parallelism
between anatomy development and um
and fossils that that was agassi
um i don't remember some some some
important biologist from early um
pointed out this parallelism between
these three things but the parallelism
does not mean
um that during say a human being's
development
you first look like a fish and then look
like a reptile and then look like an
early mammal and then look like an early
primate and then
you know it's it's not actually
recapitulating phylogeny in that way
what you
what you actually get is going from a
more general form
a form that sort of everyone in your
lineage looks like
early on into a more and more refined
and precise form such that you end up
looking like what you actually are
um so um that all aside um
the autonomy recapitulates phylomomy
development of memes recapitulates the
history of the memes
is is the is the play on words here
um and so i admit that i have a hard
time not getting stuck in like yeah but
the original isn't true so maybe this
isn't true
you know does the development of memes
simply go from the general to the
specific
just like um development you know within
in utero goes from the general to
specific
or is there something is there something
to
anatomy or recapitulates phylum all
right you gotta you gotta help me here
because um uh i
see value not in you know ontogeny does
not recapitulate phylogeny right but
there's some tendency
to recap certain things it's it's not a
total error
right it's just a it's a it's not it's
an observation with a lot of imprecision
and there's a lot of impressions and you
know stages can get deleted and stages
can get inserted and
you know there are all sorts of caveats
that you would put on it but it's not
like
you know i think the problem is hakel
overdrew this thing and he drew
you know he drew very fanciful um
drawings of of uh embryonic forms i
could find this if i had a little bit
more time
but in any case yeah um
can you give me so let's say gill slits
in an air breathing vertebrate
are an example of the pattern that led
whether it was ankle or agassi or fun
bear maybe
whoever it was yeah to um to advance
that idea
can you give me a gill-slit-like example
in which anatomy enrique pizza
recapitulates phylomomy that's the
question
but can you give me one example where it
might be true so that i
because to me i don't see any way that
memes are going to function
in any regular sense by this principle
precisely because they're lamarckian
precisely because they can jump history
they can they can jump from hilltop to
hilltop right precisely because
cultural appropriation right is
everything
yeah um not off the top of my head i
mean i imagine
i imagine there would be cases but those
would be the exceptions
right where the the meme
brings with it the development of the
meme tracks
its its own history
yeah okay but i'm not you know i
don't spend a lot of time thinking about
sort of meme phylogeny space
if the uh the questioner wanted to get
us some information
on uh you know and a couple examples
that seem to show this pattern i would
actually be really interested in knowing
if it were there
yeah all right next question
could a parasitic parasitic sentience
evolve and spread in a more
sophisticated way
as with mind viruses and if so might an
encounter with one leave a convincing
impression of possession by
an evil spirit yeah 100
and it happens all the time i mean no
totally
i mean i really don't think it's even
very much of a stretch
the influence that the social media
platforms are having on our collective
cognition
is parasitic consciousness at some level
right
so there is an explanation for what we
all think which is more garbagey than it
should be because
our conversation is being deranged by
people who don't want us unfettered
right and so that is that is parasitic
and
presumably i mean the irony is that it
is deranging their conversations too
and so they are in an arms race with
themselves are they enriching themselves
fast enough
to compensate them to compensate for
the loss of cognition that they are also
experiencing
so maybe it's not perfectly the same but
um
but yes i believe you know
or you know you could imagine imagine a
cult
a cult that diligently collected lots of
information on
its members and that resulted
in the elites in the cult being very
well informed about what was going on
while those in the cult were ever less
well informed about what was going on
such a thing could be understood to be
a parasitic consciousness riding on top
of
human consciousness right okay
somewhere in the neighborhood yeah
because trust cannot be totally
offloaded what does trustworthiness look
like with
regard to institutions and individuals
i'm not sure what the preamble means
there
there's just there's a there's a lot of
i don't know what the
because trust can't be totally offloaded
part of this question it means
um what does trustworthies
trustworthiness look like with regard to
institutions individuals those are two
very different questions
and individuals and institutions
and i think they're the same actually
um
i guess my mind goes here to one of
loyalty and to abiding by um promised
behaviors um previously promised
behaviors
and um you know to
just go back to where we started in this
q a
or what happened earlier with regard to
evergreen it was one of you know
one of the things that was most shocking
to me
that an institution that had pretended
to be
um so immensely excited by what we were
doing
so easily turned into a bastion of
disloyalty
and you know the individuals some of
them were surprising some of them
painful you know the individuals who
betrayed us but
it was really the institution-wide um
betrayal that was shocking
and i thought why then would you ever
imagine that an institution had your
back given
all of the indicators that we got um
that such a thing could never happen
there
so i want to link a couple things
together um
one that trustworthiness in both the
individual and institutional case
is a matter of the uh
willingness and obligation to do the
right thing even when it is costly
and therefore what we discovered at
evergreen which i think we knew but
it taught it in a way that was very
powerful
is that you don't really know who's
trustworthy until it's been tested
and that
that leads a lot of people to you know
risk a lot on the basis of relationships
that they just don't know
what they even mean and um so anyway
evergreen was a test and people broke
both ways
yes i did we saw lots of people who
absolutely had an obligation
to treat us better than they did and to
protect you know
frankly to protect the educational
opportunities of all of the students who
weren't engaged in this nonsense
and they didn't they did the expedient
and the reputations
of the students who got degrees from
there
that those degrees have now been
devalued and they didn't do anything to
deserve that
right so every a whole bunch of people
did the wrong thing
and it was the expedient thing and shame
on them and then a lot of people
who you know the interesting thing was
that it was actually a little bit hard
to predict who was going to break which
way
yeah and you know many people impressed
us now it was many
fewer on the faculty side right there
were a couple people on the faculty side
but it was more staff and a lot of
students a lot of students so many
students
so that was that was interesting but um
yeah and i think i think we're there you
know the the obligation to do the right
thing and
to carry through on it even when it's
costly is the key
and um you can see it in institutions
and people but only
when there's been a test yep
okay we're gonna go do a few more here
because we haven't gotten through many
of these yet
how do phenotypes and genotypes factor
into tribalism if at all
um p.s i chose 1999
as the dollar amount because it's funny
must be my phenotype
that line is funny i'm not sure why yeah
i don't know
um how do phenotypes and genotypes
factor into tribalism i mean at some
level this
this is you know to what degree to what
degree is thing are things like race and
ethnicity
um underlying
like actual race you know to the degree
that it's actually about
real underlying differences underlying
tribal differences
well i i would i would start somewhere
else okay
um i would start with the omega
principle which you can
read about in our book which later like
in months if this wasn't very nice if
there is a future
in september when it finally comes out
we've also talked about it elsewhere i
guess
yeah we could point people to our uh
princeton talk i guess
did we do i don't think we did omega
there did we i think so i don't recall
in any case um
the genes are in the driver's seat
that's very unfortunate but it's true
right culture is downstream of genes so
tribalism happens at the cultural
level but it is about genes right
now what that means is that
the genes are trying to do what they do
they use tribalism which is
superficial and cultural often um
in order to do their bidding but
then there are these synthetic tribes
that happen like the blue team and the
red team are obviously not genetic facts
right
people will argue that the red team is
acting out of
a genetic impulse i don't think the
evidence actually supports that very
well it doesn't mean that there aren't
elements of it
too but so you're talking about like the
handful of white nationalists that sort
of thing
yeah yeah right okay um but you know you
can make the same argument about the
blue team that the blue team is at this
point
you know the black lives matter
contingent so anyway
you can get tribalists so tribalism is
built by the genes to do genetic
business that the fact that tribalism
exists
can then be applied to larger things
that are not themselves genetic
it will be less stable because the
genetic underpinnings of it won't be
there
but in general um the genes built as a
means to an end you know the genes
let's put it this way the genes built
the capacity for and the tendency to
acquire
language for the purpose of enhancing
fitness
that is not a description of the limits
of what you can use language for
right it is not to say that every time
we open our mouths and say something
that it is because we are trying to
increase the number of genes in future
generations we can borrow the machinery
for something else
and that is frequently happening with
tribalism but
where it came from is surely genetic
very good um
i've convinced my brother that the lab
leak is a likely possibility
his wife is a nurse however i think
healthcare workers are being brainwashed
by the cdc
why um
well they may be inadvertently um
i brainwashed i would i would be
surprised if they were being targeted
specifically
i mean i don't i can be surprised by a
lot at this point though right
um but you know it just doesn't seem
like a
let's put it this way if you're a
healthcare worker
you more or less have to sign up for the
idea
that best practices will be delivered
through a centralized mechanism
that tells you what to do how to behave
all these things and if you decide
hey i don't trust that centralized
mechanism you immediately have many
problems
so in general the system will both
select for people who will accept it
and b uh people will accept it because
there's no telling how they would
navigate it the situation in which they
rejected it so
at some level the cdc is a conduit
that a bunch of people are plugged into
as a here's what to think about this and
here's how to behave in response
and it's not surprising that this flows
down that conduit no and i mean this is
this is why you know
this we need antitrust and medicine just
like we need antitrust everywhere
right like you know why why should we
encourage
do's to continue existing and doing
their amazing thing
while mds are also doing their thing
because just having two different lines
of inquiry with different um with
different biases and different
approaches
is a corrective on the other and i would
say the same thing for like
you know the birth industry like you
know okay if you want
an ob gyn and a hospital birth cool
um and if you you know
really think that you are you know
likely to be at risk of like getting a
c-section because of some you know some
history
and you therefore want to go like
midwifer doula or some combination root
it's beautiful that we actually have
that as an option now that
and still most insurances at least in
the u.s seem to seem to tolerate that
and saying that you want one or the
other
is not inherently a rejection of the
other
um but having the choice is absolutely
necessary because
otherwise you know just just like you
say you know a nurse
a nurse in any cis like i i don't
imagine you know how how could you
possibly
deal with independence of thought with
regard to anything going on covet wise
as a practicing nurse right now i don't
know how you do it like
the cognitive dissonance would be nearly
impossible because you
can't talk about that [ __ ] at work i
imagine yep
i imagine yeah i can't see how you would
yeah
you said that seeing doctor oh related
question-ish
you said that seeing doctors can still
be okay but for how long
with woke anti-science reverse
oppression coming what signals the end
say the trusted gp refers you to a woke
doctor do many non-woke plan to give up
doctors
or what yeah i mean i think i'm
there are there's definitely woo-woo
non-scientific
you know health care options out there
and some of those people probably
actually have insight and they just
don't know why they have it and they've
like stumbled into some
little place where they can practice
even though they don't have
training but i would say you know the
main the main one that i've discovered
is exactly this that you know
increasingly med schools are woke
and people trained in the in the main
way are are
increasingly susceptible to this kind of
thinking and
my you know very tiny um
you know anecdotal experience of the you
know parallel way that doctors get
trained and certified um in the western
world right now which is
um to say doctors of osteopathy as
opposed to doctors of medicine but they
have all the same prescribing
privileges you know hospital privileges
all of this um
is that um do's who spend you know who
who prioritize hands-on work and
spending more time with patients and
doing
really deep patient histories and really
trying to understand root cause
including
like embryological causes um
are less likely to be susceptible to the
you know fashion wins of the moment yeah
it doesn't target them for one thing
yeah yeah um i don't know how to read
that
[Music]
do you know how i read that no yep zach
knows how we read it
yeah so okay
oh oh okay got it yeah
um so this is um deep [ __ ] value
which who zack our 16 year old and
producer um
reminds us is the reddit user
uh involved in one of them involving
gamestop so deep [ __ ] value still
likes the stock
if he's still in i'm still in the only
difference between him and me is he
bought at five dollars and i bought it
350
dollars i'll be driving a bentley soon
there was a right hearing uh
congressional hearing
two days ago that included uh him keith
gail i believe and the ceo of robin hood
and various others like ceos of civil
and melbourne
so this is very relevant right now just
know that
okay so zach i assume no one can hear
what zach just said except for us
zach said that two days ago there's a
congressional hearing with uh
this this guy and what the ceo of robin
hood you said
um and i don't know what i didn't know
that so i don't know
um anyway obviously if you spent 70
70 times the amount um as deep [ __ ]
value did on the stock you're not going
to be making quite as much
yeah i don't want to touch this one with
a barge pole yeah because the dynamics
in question are presumably
uh unpredictable um right so
my girlfriend just graduated with a
bachelor's in public health
any advice for those trying to pursue
employment in the field
even contact tracing jobs appear hard to
come by
i don't i just don't i got nothing yeah
okay let's do let's do three more i'm
going to drop to the bottom for the last
one
um brett have you ever felt stockholm
syndrome out of school
i never found stockholm syndrome i'm
trying to parse that
what would i have fallen in love with
being out of school yes i
like being out of school is that the
question i'm not sure
um yeah i don't have i ever felt
stockholm syndrome
being out of school you mean do i miss
my captors
in school oh maybe that yeah do you ever
wish you were a student again
wow no i do not wish i was a student
again
i liked being a professor quite a bit
but
only in the context where i had the
freedom to arrange my teaching life so
that i wasn't constantly tripping over
things i'm not good at
right right so i do miss that but you
know
in general no and as i'm watching the
academy go
increasingly insane uh there is a
um you know there but for the grace of
god
go we yeah yeah totally uh can you
impersonate tim
jay dylan um
can i improv can i impersonate him yeah
i
i haven't i've still never seen him so i
can't no
no okay no the answer is no no and the
final question is are you funded in any
way by gates
i mean how would we even know
um no that's not a cool answer dude
that's a terrible answer um we are
not funded in any way why would you even
do that
because i was playing on the idea that
he's
he's got his tendrils and everything but
yeah um
no we are not we are certain that we are
not funded in any way
well you know who knows who knows who
you know
somebody is bill gates you know watching
darkhorse and
bill gates just give the 299 to ask us
2.99 cents to ask us to impersonate tim
dillon of which youtube will take 40
percent
right there you go possible cannot rule
it out
but no no in no way we know of yeah
um okay well i don't i don't like how
that ended so i'm going to try another
one
i don't know what the best laid plans of
my salmon means
but that sounds good okay here's
here's one my children have some of my
very particular childhood idiosyncrasies
that i've since grown out of
they've never seen my childhood behavior
yet i see a lot of me and their actions
does dna echo some sort of a memory that
passes through to children
um i would say you want to be super
cautious
people are always leaping to the
conclusion that dna
has to be the mechanism and even they do
this
when their own children manifest
behavior that is reminiscent of their
behavior as is the case here
and i would just point out yes one way
for this to travel
outside of dna would be for your
children to have seen the behavior and
picked it up
but another way it could happen is that
the behavior in question
could be the result of some combination
of other characteristics you have
that when put together caused the
pattern in question
and your kids could have picked up those
things independently and they could have
come together in the same way in those
kids
and they would manifest the same thing
and so anyway am i saying it's not
dna can't say that but i can say
you got to be imaginative about all of
the ways in which
behavioral patterns could be transmitted
outside of the genome and rule them out
before you leap to the conclusion that
it's definitely dna you're seeing
there are lots of other ways i mean even
just you know
i wish i had a good example but even
just your
bodily idiosyncrasies you know the
relative proportions of your limbs for
example could result in you engaging the
world in a particular way which would
result in you making similar discoveries
which would result in you having a
particular mindset that might be
recognizable
and it might be reinforced by other
things you do that even though the
initial behavior had been lost
the behaviors that were downstream of it
in time
have been retained and they could
reinforce there are lots of ways it
could happen
you know dna is cool and interesting but
we've been
way too obsessed with it we are of
course also
um prone to confirmation bias so we see
the things that remind us of ourselves
when we are children and our children
and we don't inherently notice all the
things that they do that aren't like
what we did
yep um i was just thinking you know just
the other day
i'm going to tell a tiny little story on
you zach here zach
fell up the stairs which is something i
did a ton at his age
i was just like in gangly and leggy and
i would just like
fall up the stairs all the time i'm the
same way with ladders
no you're not no no i'm not
you're really not and i don't you know
and i i said to him
i used to do that all the time and you
know i noticed it because
other people don't report falling
upstairs a lot as teenagers so
you know is that is that because he's
got something
like maybe he and i have similar limb
length relative you know to
torso length and growth rates at this
particular stage in development
something something something yeah
yeah yeah like that like that okay
um i think we are at the end that's it i
think we're all right
um let us remind
everyone zak almost just took us out um
so we'll be back next week um
join us at my patreon um
to ask questions for private q a now
for private q a next sunday not tomorrow
join brett his patreon
check out the clips channel um
yeah lots of other stuff yeah engage in
awesomeness but not recreational
awesomeness
engage in recreational awesomeness all
right but
be aware of whether it's recreational
awesomeness or
non-recreational awesomeness don't
overthink your awesomeness
don't underthink it either though all
right get outside
are you talking to me yes all right bye
everybody we'll see you next time
you